is it time to stop eating meat i suppose
i could pick you up both on the spot
here emily i know are you a vegan
vegetarian should we be
i'm not a vegan vegetarian but i do eat
an awful lot less meat than i once did
and and i think that's no that's the
most important thing it's about
moderation um the other thing that's
really critically important is just
wasting less food the amount of food
waste is really shocking um it's
estimated that some 20 billion pounds
worth of food waste is produced in the
uk each year and an awful lot of that is
edible food that's just being thrown
away um something like 20 million slices
of bread that could be eaten put in a
bin each year it's complete waste and
the emissions associated with that are
all the way from the emissions
associated with growing that food in the
first place processing it packaging it
transporting it as well as then what
happens when it's thrown away and
potentially sent to landfill so there's
an awful lot that can be done additional
to looking at your diet um just to
reduce the amount that we're wasting
yeah informing your choice is so
important isn't it and when you're
looking at some of the alternatives that
you can pursue it's important to know as
well about the provenance of those
alternatives you look at the simple fact
here about avocados and you realize
actually you think you're doing virtuous
thing but there's a lot of water that
goes into the production of avocados how
do people inform their choices dan
well that's that's really really
difficult i mean i've echo emily really
so
getting rid of you know meat and fish
intake entirely is quite difficult uh
reducing it um significantly is actually
easy enough i found that easy enough but
it's not just about going cold turkey
excuse the pun you know there's actually
going to be a very large uh plant-based
meat market uh possibly worth by 35
billion by 2027 according to uh unilever
and you know veganism and vegetarian is
on the rise uh around the world but as i
say you don't have to completely go
meat-free or fish-free it has to be a
choice and people have to want to do it
at the end of the day though locally
sourced seasonal fruit and veg remains
you know the best the best option on the
table yeah what do you think about this
proposal in the netherlands emily to
force farmers to cut down on the number
of livestock is it do we need radical
solutions
actually i think the critical thing is
to work with farmers to look at how they
can reduce their emissions and that's
something that we've been doing locally
in around cambridge working with the
farmers to see how they can alter their
farming practices in a way that has
dramatically less impact um on the
environment and actually ends up being
beneficial for the farming processes
themselves as well in many instances
yeah do you agree with that just briefly
dan
yeah i think you have to take people on
on the journey i don't think people will
do as we've seen over the last you know
whatever period of time people don't
necessarily want to be forced to do
things but the dutch are pretty
progressive the netherlands is pretty
progressive about things like gas
boilers as well and not having them uh
installed but you've got to socialize
that uh with the market and having you
know living in a low low-lying land with
a dike since the end of your garden
really focuses